your heart drops is this it is this the
moment the company dies
tom bloomfield entrepreneur investor and
founder of monzo
i've never actually talked about this
before after six months i just thought i
can't work with this person i just
really it's
really damaging to me and my mental
health and so i resigned and the
response to that resignation
she called nor house meeting and fired
the entire company
if i knew then what i knew now i would
never have done it really if i knew what
the amount of pain and heartache
that would be involved i would never
have started but i didn't know that i
cry quite a lot
you know i'm not ashamed of that for
about three or four seconds
i'd forgotten what my life was i was
calm and then
three or four seconds later all the
memories came back it was just like this
crushing weight
that really was the moment i sort of
knew this is this is no life
there were no other emotions in my life
really apart from just anxiety
i mean it was serious by the end we
would detect criminals and shut their
accounts down customs would turn up
sometimes with weapons
and they threatened to turn up with you
know a bottle of acid and throw it in
someone's face
that was tough
[Music]
tom bloomfield what a remarkable
entrepreneur
one of the uk's recent real success
stories and he
and his team managed to disrupt the
archaic
incumbent banking system at a time when
nobody thought it could be disrupted
but man his story is crazy
absolutely crazy and the reason why i
started the diary of a ceo
is demonstrated perfectly
in this podcast it has it all
controversy
drama business wars depression
anxiety resilience success
and failure and today you're going to
hear a particular business story
one that's never been heard before but
tom felt that today
and here was the place to share it if
you're an aspiring entrepreneur
and you want to get to the point in your
life where you're running a hundred
million or a billion pound company
today might be your warning because as
tom is going to tell
you all that glitters is in gold
and the true cost of entrepreneurship
the cost that nobody seems to talk about
is sometimes greater than the reward on
offer
this is one of the most emotional raw
honest vulnerable
brilliant gripping conversations i've
ever had on this podcast
and i can't thank tom enough for opening
up his diary
and allowing us to look inside
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
tom why why entrepreneurship
i made a very bad employee
i've never been promoted and i've been
fired i would guess two or three times
depending on how you count
why were you fired so often um
my first ever job was a consulting firm
in london
i actually wasn't fired from this one i
was um but i wasn't promoted
and they said i was uh highly disruptive
and not in a good way
not in a sort of you know tech found
disrupts industry more in sort of
you know annoying junior analysts can't
follow instructions
so i think i'm much i'm much better
founder than i am an employee
what was it about you that was
disruptive though i want some specifics
um whenever i'm i see a problem i think
that this is in common with anyone who
starts a business i look at
the way something's done and immediately
start thinking of better ways to do it
rather than just doing what i'm told i
sort of scratch my head and think no
it just doesn't make sense to me why are
we doing it this way that we could do
this other way which is ten times faster
i mean i one of my first ever jobs was
to
uh with another analyst go and count all
of the jewelry
items on a like a massive jewelry
website it must be a thousand to do a
tally chart of the price range
and this guy i started doing by hand so
i scratched my head and wrote a little
excel script to script basically scrape
the website and just tally them up and
go
there's your results and but they didn't
want that because they were billing by
the hour and
that'd only taken an hour of my time
rather than 20 hours and so they could
only bill
me out for an hour like no no go back
and do it by hand so it
that kind of stuff just drove me crazy
and i was always just looking for
ways to automate ways to do things
better um i guess that's what led me
into entrepreneurship
have you heard about this idea of first
principle thinking absolutely yeah
my co-founder jonas at monzo was just i
think he would say first principal
thinking at least once a day
because that's that sounds to me like
first principle thinking you're looking
at
conventions way of doing things and
thinking well no this is there's a much
easier yeah absolutely you sort of start
from physics and build build up from
there really
how's that how's that voted for you in
your in your personal life though so
because life is personal life is full of
convention marriage school
follow this path do you know what i mean
yeah and i you know i
i'm not married but certainly when i was
younger i followed that conventional
path i i went to a grammar school i did
my exams i got a place at oxford
um i even did a master's at oxford so i
sort of i was following that
conventional path towards becoming a
lawyer i guess but
somewhere along the way i started
realizing it probably wasn't for me but
definitely
in the early years that was my path you
built this hyper fast growing business
which was you know funny that you used
the word disrupter which was known as
one of the uk's great disrupters
and still is known as one of the uk
great disruptors um
can you tell me why like because i when
i
when i speak to shaq do you know shaq
shaquille khan about
daniel eck and when i think about your
story
you both made the decision to take on
just
what what many entrepreneurs would
consider to be an immovable object you
took on the banking system
um danielek took on the in this massive
music industry that was seemed to be
immune to change i was talking to shaq
about this last week oh really he texted
me last night about um
about harry's new fund so he i think
that's why he's fresh of mine
what gave you the conviction and the
confidence that you could
take on such a mammoth industry with
monzo
um i mean arrogance for naivety and
arrogance i think in no small part
um i i'd already built a company called
gocardless which is a payment processor
so that sort of
taught me that you know three young guys
could get access to the payment system
and actually move money around
um and banking was a step up from there
it was it was more regulated more
complicated
but i had the background in payments and
i was an early natwest user
or rather when i was young and they were
very old i was a network user and i was
deeply deeply disappointed
and i think like any founder really a
huge
sort of dose of naivety you know you
look at a problem and think it's
probably
i think if i knew now what i knew if i
knew then what i knew now
i would never have done it really if i
knew what the amount of pain and
heartache
that would be involved i would never
have started but i didn't know that and
so i had a huge amount of
self-confidence huge amount of naivety
and just assumed that i could figure it
out and i think we got a really really
long way and i mean
the company's still doing fabulously so
i'm incredibly proud of
of what we built i find that point about
naivety so interesting
because it almost feels like founders
like yourself need to be
deluded on one end in terms of their own
confidence
yep right because if you look at the
stats and all the odds
they're clearly against you so founders
like yourself seem to be
i deleted sounds like a negative word
but it's like for me i'm saying in a
positive way
almost like deluded to the or naive to
the the stats and the probability of
this
success yeah totally but also self-aware
enough to
listen to feedback and to not be blinded
by
their hypotheses listen to some feedback
i mean a lot of the feedback i got in
the early days was this is impossible
you can never do it
you know go back to your day job um so i
think you do have to be incredibly
optimistic as well
but a little bit like investing i'm
doing a little bit of investing now
i think you if you have a lot of
experience the downside is you've seen
these ideas fail again and again and
again
and it's really hard to then leave that
baggage behind
and look at a company um i looked at one
yesterday it's like i i've seen that
model
fail four times not my you know i wasn't
running it others were running it but
to um have a fresh enough mind to think
okay maybe the timing's different maybe
the founding team's different maybe the
technology's changed
this can now work so i think actually
the benefit of being naive and
even being quite young in your career is
you don't have that baggage of knowing
how it failed the five times before
um which i i find super interesting when
you're looking at founders in your
investments now
from your own experience of being a
founder yeah what are the attributes
you're looking for
i mean the really simple one is being
technical being able to write code i
think is just a huge huge
leg up and all of the founders who
aren't technical and there are many
great ones
um i think the biggest problem the early
stage is finding a technical co-founder
so that's just a
an immediate benefit and if if i could
talk to my
um if i could talk to people in a sort
of if age 12 to 18 i would basically
just go and say
learn to code you're going to have a
really well paying career
for the rest of your life and it'll it's
a great step into entrepreneurship
are you technical yeah i learned to code
when i was 12 or 13.
bit websites um i mean i was never
i studied law not computer science but i
can i can code i there's still code i
wrote probably in the monza code base
somewhere
i think it puts the emojis into the the
push notifications but um
yeah so being technical i think is just
the easy answer um
more fundamentally i think just being
really really determined and resilient
seeing as you said an immovable object
and either finding a way
sort of round it or over or under it or
just straight through it it is some
that um being indifferential basically i
think is
is the single biggest predictor of
success you um
you strike me as someone that has great
confidence and i imagine that's come
from
as you kind of alluded to with go
cardless you've built evidence over time
that you could do things so i i i
sometimes think of confidence as like a
self-reinforcing
cycle either upwards or downwards um i
think i was more confident when i was 28
than i am now for sure and i think that
comes with
experience um i think you
you take enough knocks that you start to
and you realize you don't know i think
at 27 28 i thought i knew everything and
now i realize
i you know i like to think i know a lot
about a lot of things but
i realize i don't um and so my i'm still
a confident person i'd guess but if you
put me in front of my 27 year old self
i think you would see two different
people
maybe less naivety maybe that would be
yeah exactly yeah i've seen the failures
a few times now
because i i was saying that because
there's a lot of um a lot of young
people in my
in my dms that are dreaming big dreams
like yours but they would just never
have the
confidence or conviction to pursue them
so i was wondering is that i'm trying to
get to i guess the crux of what made
you so starkly different from every all
of the young people that have
at least verbalized equally big dreams
i think i'm also just really impulsive
so i
i think quite self-confident but i was
um i've taken quite big life decisions
without very much reflection
um and that's worked out really well i'm
you know i'm hugely privileged i
um i've grown up in the uk which i think
is enormous privilege compared to a lot
you know
people in my position but growing up in
in rural africa are not going to have
the same opportunity i have great
education i had parents who supported me
and i knew i could take risk because if
that risk didn't pay off
i've have i have that safety net and so
um yes i was confident
i think yes i was impulsive but i that
was enabled from a place of huge
privilege because i could
take the risk and i actually think
people
in this country um with great supportive
families don't take enough risk in
general
i think people go into pretty safe
careers in
law or consulting or whatever and i
think they could
do more interesting things have more
impact make more money if that's what
drives you by taking more risk i just
don't think they do you know
i think i put myself on the risk-loving
end of the spectrum um and so i've quit
jobs and moved countries
you know with like hours notice um i
started go cardless
with matt hiroki because i quit my
consulting job to go to a bigger
consultancy and in that gardening leave
i just got bored i had three months off
and they said let's
start a website and i said yes and then
my combination said come out and
interview and we did and we got the
offer to do y combinator and their
investment about
three days before my mckinsey start date
so i just sort of said ah this sounds
fun i'll i'll do the startup thing
instead
you launched gocardless you take that to
i think a nine figure valuation
uh it's 970 million dollars at their
last round
i believe that's what was reported so
not quite a billion
um okay 10 figures
i mean that is a that is an achievement
that most people in their lifetimes
would
you know would never go near um in of
itself you you then
depart go cardless i left early um i we
were 35 people you know it was a
the valuation was in the region of 30 or
40 million at the time
hiroki my co-founder at time um
i took on the ceo role and it's done
just a phenomenal job
i'm just ten and a half years old now
it's and it's but it's been
that was not an overnight success story
that was ten and a half years of really
really hard work
and huge credit to him and matt also who
who stuck around a lot longer than me i
was there for the first three years i
think
i put something of myself into it but it
was i was there for
the beginning not the uh not the middle
and certainly not the end why did you
leave
i wasn't really pat i think it's a great
company but i wasn't really passionate
about
b2b direct debit software right it helps
you know um
lots of different uh suppliers collect
money from their customers
um in a sort of back-office way it
didn't have a big consumer brand it
wasn't
direct to consumer really and i didn't
b2b sales i found uh really difficult
and frustrating and not something i was
good at
and the tech kind of was built um and
that had been my role
so i sort of i went from there to join a
dating site which is like the polar
opposite
you know uh all about brand direct to
consumer
um really fun every day uh terrible
business model
that was one of the ones i got fired
from um i was head of growth that we
stopped growing
um it was bad you were head of growth
and you stopped
and the company stopped growing very
self-aware and honest for you to admit
that
um and in fact i saw the charts and it
looked like a rocket ship when i was
sort of interviewing there
for crazy 48 hour interview process i
flew out to new york they showed me some
of their growth charts really
sort of hockey stick metrics um and then
it all just started to plateau and i
kind of ignored that yeah i said okay
that's my job to come in it had
flattened out and i joined to kind of
reignite
and i didn't i wasn't able to reignite
it we sort of plateaued along for
about 10 months and then it fell off a
cliff revenue declined 70
um within about two to four weeks
without any kind of macroeconomic
this wasn't covered or something this
was back in 2014. the world was going
well
the dating site just was no longer cool
i think um so we rode this wave of
popularity and sort of zeitgeist um it
was called grouper it was it was
incredibly
sort of cool novel idea back in 2013-14
um and then people just got bored of it
i think
so the idea was um it was six of you
three three guys and three girls or
three guys and three guys if that's your
your preference um or three girls and
three girls
um but six of you you and two friends
would go and meet three other people
so you knew your friends and they knew
each other and it would put the group
together you need to kind of
go and have a wild night out um rather
than traditional dating
apps sort of one-on-one this was sort of
a group social experience
uh really really fun but um not a great
business model
you got fired uh yeah most the company
got laid off actually
yeah and then you took how long off
before you swung back into the next
thing
um so i uh
about two months but only
about two months um because it was the
u.s i
was on a weird visa this is not
interesting but basically i couldn't
take another job and i couldn't
as soon as i crossed the us border my
visa expired yes i've yeah
but whilst i was there i could stay
there for actually two years or
something
um so i just spent a summer in new york
chilling out and then came back to the
uk and i think
about 48 hours after arriving in the uk
i met up with
ann bowdan at starling and agreed to be
their cto within about
again 24 hours um and there's a lot
written about
how i mean how your relationship with
and transpired and your relationship
with
stalin more broadly transpired what's
what are what are the key highlights
from that from that journey
choose your co-founder really carefully
yeah uh i mean there were 14 of us at
starling
and 13 of us started monso it was that
stuck
wait say that again 14 people at
starling and 13 of you started monzo
13 of those 14 started 13 of those 14
started monday
okay including the chairman of the board
um the entire management team the office
manager everyone
so one one would say well you know tom
must have ripped them all away
[Laughter]
no no i just didn't want to work with
anne
like really i've never actually talked
about this before and there was there
has been a book i haven't read the book
uh the brief version is after six months
i got fired twice
in six months um i was never paid i
invested my own money which is i lost
um there was never any paperwork which
is my fault um
and after six months i just thought i
can't work with this person i just
really it's
really damaging to me and my mental
health and so i resigned
and the response to that resignation she
called an all hands meeting
and fired the entire company
because you resigned yep so i didn't i
didn't pull anyone away she fired the
entire company
that's not true two people happened to
not be in the office so they weren't at
the meeting where they got fired
so they had to work two weeks notice
because they weren't technically fired
but everyone else was fired so we all
went to this gin bar to kind of
it was called ask for janus on
smithfield market it's a great buy you
should go there
um we all went there to basically
commiserate just think this is crazy
what's just happened and literally it's
i think we were there for two days
basically in this gin bar playing we we
all played speed chess it was this very
nerdy kind of
four players we're playing lots and lots
of bhs uh just trying to figure out what
we're gonna do and eventually like we
can
um we think we can do this ourselves um
so
it wasn't a case of like you know me
leading a coo me pulling the company
away i quit
i was just like good luck to you i'm
just i'm going to sit on a beach for a
while
and in response she fired the entire
company which is just
i think a reflection of the way she she
operates
i can't quite wrap my head around the
idea of one person
resigning and then firing everybody as a
show of
i don't even know no it's not something
i would do
where did that leave starling though if
they only if they'd lost pretty much
everybody other than the two people that
didn't manage to make it into work that
day and they also resigned the day after
yeah to come and work with us
um she hired another management team
another oh really
okay and it turned out that we weren't
the first team there'd been a previous
team as well
oh wow that she'd fired wow
and then off so that's that's crazy so
you started essentially monzo was
founded in that gin bar yep yep asked
for janice
and it's still there we go back for some
of our reunions really
yeah yeah yeah and how did you feel so
you're fired
you know from starling you all convene
in this gin bar you spend a couple of
days there you end up
um deciding that you're gonna go again
together yep and
i guess you feel pretty fired up and
charged up to
not only disrupt the industry but also
to compete with starling though
um it was unavoidable that feeling of
[ __ ] them kind of but
we didn't i didn't really know that that
she you know and was going to rehire a
bunch of people
it was over right and there was a big
feeling of like we put quite a lot of
work into this actually and like we've
had to leave everything behind so we
came to
you know rewrite the code base redo all
our regulatory submissions really from
scratch which was kind of like a
oh i wish we didn't have to do this but
we did um
[Music]
but in a way it actually led us we'd
made the mistakes once the first time so
actually that sort of rebuilding process
was nice because it was on fresh ground
but yeah it felt like a i mean initially
we tried to negotiate with that and say
why did you know
why did you step down why do like how
can we we don't want to throw away this
side
for some people they've been there 12
months why are we throwing away 12
months of work
and that was a sort of very convoluted
week or two um where we almost had a
deal a couple of times and it just
similar thing happened you know huge
blow up and we just walked away
um but no we never i think at monza we
never really thought about the
competition actually
it wasn't a you know we weren't looking
over our shoulder at revolut or styling
it was
uh if anything we were looking at the
big banks thinking how can we take
market share off them
co-founders when you started monzo you
started with was was paul
ripping your only co-founder no uh there
were f uh
and it was a it was sort of weird
actually because of 13 of us
like how do you pick which ones are you
all they were all literally there on day
one
um so in a sense that was the founding
team and they all got stock like not
options
actually full you know stock um but the
for
arbitrary reasons which i can't really
remember there were five of us so myself
paul um became deputy ceo and was the
chief risk officer
he became deputy ceo because the bank of
england looked at me and i think i was
29 or 30 or something i said you
have you ever worked in a bank no it's
like and you're applying to be ceo of
our newest bank
yes and they sort of scratch your head
for a bit and said how about this
sort of very experienced guy next to you
this co-founder of yours
how about they didn't say that they said
we'd like you to find a deputy ceo who's
actually run a bank before please
and i you know i said paul has won
several banks so he became deputy
a ceo gary was cfo um he'd been at
abn amro and mizuho bank i think
uh there's a guy called jason who is
sort of more customer marketing
and then jonas who is the only one left
now
was a cto really really talented
developer um
so he stepped into the cta how important
is that you talked
earlier about the importance of business
partners and that being one of your
big regrets but how critically important
is because you know
definitely one of the biggest mistakes i
made in my career was when i was very
young just hired anybody
because i thought you know like oh you
like i remember being in selfridges one
day
there was a guy selling prada bags so
like you can be a director you know what
i mean
because you don't know what you don't
know
i didn't do that i did i was thinking i
was like 18
so um but i
in hindsight i i know it's the most well
for me
that core team is the most important
thing yeah it's probably the single
biggest determining factor of successful
failure in my view
yeah so how important what was it for
you to assemble
um that skilled co-founding
team i mean it was it was luck at monzo
because that was the
group that was uh starting and it was
sort of like how do we keep this team
together and it really was
sort of it felt like everyone's going to
disappear into the wind um
there was a you know it really was a
debate are we going to
really try and do this again or you know
is this it we just go back to whatever
we were doing before and so
to keep everyone together i think it
wasn't a and so
i think we were really fortunate we had
such a great um different set of skills
um but it wasn't hugely uh sort of
planned
no i have a another example of this i
started a company
when i was at university through young
enterprise
and on day one they were like 14
co-found co-founders of this business
which is just a ridiculous way to start
a company and within about two
we had meetings meetings nothing ever
got done so within three months or so
three of us basically said look you 11.
you can have
right on your seat that's what you want
but you know you're not really
here to run a business the three of
actually are gonna like work all summer
um one of them uh quit his job to do
he just left to work at deutsche bank
and then three hours are actually going
to try and run a startup here
and so figuring out that core team i
think is is really really important to
get right and having a group of
14 is not the way to do it really when
you when you started monzo from that
i say from the gym but it wasn't really
from the gym bar but you see what i mean
that was the kind of
i guess the inception moment um what was
the driving force for you
to go on that journey was it money was
it
the chance of you know moving an
industry what was it
oh gosh uh insecurity i think for me it
was i was
much of the reason i started my business
was probably based on deep
childhood insecurities about wanting to
be rich and
yeah like all of that i think tied up
into a bunch of weird sort of
deep-rooted psychological problems um
wanting to prove myself wanting to win
or
wanting to be seen to be successful i
think
um that money played a part in it not
the driving part but certainly there was
a factor there
um a deep hatred for natwest bank
um why they're just incredibly
frustrating to use
just every everyone who came to work at
monto had
one of these horror stories about their
banks you know
matt one of our early developers went
10p overdrawn with a
a different bank and paid the 10p in
um and then closed it counts like i'm
done with this but
he'd incurred the chart he didn't know
they applied the charge at the end of
month so it's like a
five pound overdraft fee that month
which then the month after a month after
a month after should have rolled and
rolled and rolled and rolled and two up
you know two years later they came after
him for several thousand pounds
because he'd been 10p overdrawn for a
day um just
everyone's got those kind of stories and
so a big part of it was a frustration
that banking worked like that
and a sort of feeling that it didn't
have to be like that because we looked
at apps like spotify or
or uber and they felt magical you know
the i
the people who've grown up with that
technology it's sort of normal now but i
remember you know i downloaded nap stuff
for the first time i remember showing my
dad and my uncle
you know think of any song you want in
the world yeah type it in
and it starts playing and that's that is
magical
um but now it's so commonplace and
banking for years has just been
you want to change change your address
down i've downloaded a form filled in
the form assigned and had to post it off
this is for an online bank
um so we really just felt quite deeply
that it could be
the experience could be much much better
do you want to come in and watch this
podcast live from behind the scenes if
you do
all you have to do is hit the subscribe
button and now that the world has opened
up
you'll be behind the scenes as many of
our subscribers have been i can't wait
to meet you
and one of the other reasons you gave
there as a driving force was wanting to
be seen to win
yeah or can you explain that one
not to win i think that's probably the
wrong i i use that phrase but i
to be seen to be a success i think like
validation yeah kind of yeah you know
that's to my family and my friends and
my school
and teachers and um
you've already been a success though
with gocardless did you
yeah i had a bit but go kardas
circa 2014 2015 was
still relatively unknown it was doing
well but not it wasn't a breakout
success yet in the way it is today i
think um just on that feeling of
wanting that validation from friends
because we can all relate to that like
i'm i'm
playing devil's advocate but i know
exactly what you mean you're on a tv
show
exactly exactly and i'm doing a podcast
17 cameras right now
um but uh but just drilling down into
that in hindsight
was that a feeling that you think could
have ever
been attained um was it a mirage
i think i have attained it yeah oh
i know i don't mean i'm the world's big
success that's not what i mean i mean
that like
i've tasted what that feels like that's
mixing my metaphors there i felt what
that feel you know i've experienced
that thing that's sort of like being in
the newspapers and that sort of
um people using in monzo card and that
stuff
and it's
somewhat rewarding but it's not like i
and i don't feel anymore
i think what i'm trying to say is sort
of that need to prove myself has sort of
disappeared
actually um and so either i've realized
it was a stupid goal to start with or
like
i got far enough along that i sort of
like take that off the list and sort of
thought you know that sort of it was fun
but it's not my overriding purpose now
um and i'm not i'm your next question
what is your purpose
i'm not sure i have one it's sort of
more like living day to day and enjoying
life and i
i was never good at that i've really
really driven from a very very young age
so i
worked incredibly hard for my exams and
my you know
through oxford and starting companies um
and
very rarely paused to enjoy the journey
or the you know the
cliche the small things in life the you
know the
choose your cliche right like how your
coffee tastes in the morning or the sort
of
the tweeting of the birds in the in the
trees
and that stuff now i'm am spending more
time kind of being more i guess mindful
and kind of
living in the moment do you have to like
reprogram yourself to get there though
because i feel like society well for me
anyway
is um kind of conditions you to to
chase climb promote move up strive
and and you're kind of deferring your
happiness to towards some future
achievement accomplishment yeah so how
did you get to the point where you just
enjoy it what it you know life for what
it is in the moment
was it reprogramming yeah i guess like
you know like you
i i left my company i didn't um and that
was
really really hard and that was not a
that was
um you know deep deep anxiety and
bordering on depression and
uh like i i i wouldn't use the words
rock bottom
but like it was not a happy time and so
then recovering from that
uh and i took a year off and you know
travel around europe went kite surfing
and learned the language and all this
kind of you know cliches
um and that experience now
leads me uh whenever i i still get these
like urges like
sort of um they my local mp passed away
a few months ago and there was a
by-election i was like why did i why did
i stand for that seat and i could be
an mp and then maybe i could you know
maybe it could be the prime minister
and then i'm like but then what
crap yeah exactly and
you know i think like i could start a
company
and then you know what if it goes well
and then i end up running a big company
again
so uh yeah just like a couple of sort of
those brain cycles and i'm like
no what am i what am i thinking um i
quite quickly come back to like i'm
really enjoying my life at the moment
i'm lucky enough that i'm financially
sort of independent now i have a great
group of friends like
why um why do i want to go and make
myself miserable again
um where does that narrative that voice
come from so many people have that way
because
it's funny because you're saying right
i'm i'm a i'm at a stage of peace now
i wasn't before but you still have that
yearning or that voice that comes and
goes come on tom do it
um it's that it's that sort of i guess
disruptive kind of
um i see something that's not working
and it's incredibly frustrating and i
go i could i could make that work better
i'm um
i'm uh
reluctant i've talked about this before
i'm working in the in the i'm
volunteering the vaccination program and
it sounds like a sort of
i'm proud of doing it and it's like a
great feeling kind of being part of
a team that's uh
hopefully helping kind of the country
get out of this lockdown rubbish
but even there there are so many things
that just drive me absolutely nuts
um and i think that's probably nhs sort
of more broadly i think the smart use of
technology could really really improve
the way we deliver care to
everyone really medical care and so i
keep thinking i just want to like just
give me
you know experience um i just yeah why
can't i just come in and fix it for a
you know it's incredibly
you know i've struggled with a company
of 2000 people the nhs employees i think
a million and a half people or something
so
um probably not for me but there's
always that like
your question you know what what is that
drive it's the
looking at something that's like clearly
broken at least to my naive eyes
um and that feeling that i feel like
along with a
small group of smart people i could make
it better okay quick one
if you've listened to this podcast you
know i'm the biggest fan of fuel in the
world and
last week huel released hule's brand new
protein powders
and i have to tell you the salted
caramel huel protein powder which only
has a hundred calories in it roughly
and 20 grams of protein has become my
go-to drink and you can if you're
watching this on youtube you'll see i'm
going to open that
it's almost almost nearly done and i've
had it for a week
um but i've been looking for a source of
protein that is also low calories and
that tastes like heaven on earth
and i finally found it so if i was to
put my word
to you next to a product it would be
hewls
salted caramel new protein powders 20
grams of protein
26 of your vitamins and minerals in case
you're not nutritionally complete or
sort of
getting all of your vitamins and
minerals and that 105
calories in a serving and it tastes like
heaven on earth what were the the good
times at monzo the times you look back
most fondly
small team so sub 100
[Music]
being able to um
go from a kind of an idea or a customer
insight or something like a conversation
with a customer
about a problem to figuring out a kind
of product feature to
very quickly prototyping and building
that and launching it and then seeing
people
use it um and then tell their friends
about it that very quick iterative
product development cycle i love
um and a lot of the brand and marketing
stuff
uh i when i was at gocardless i didn't
believe in brand
uh which is a ridiculous thing to say um
and i you know
you has a marketing background that's
almost offensive i guess but
it's like no this is you know this
doesn't this doesn't exist really people
um and then the day when i worked at the
dating site that really opened my eyes
to the kind of
power of human psychology and brand and
and mission and values
and we really took a lot of that into
monsoon and that it it was just
astonishing
so we started out even before we had a
product talking a lot about our mission
and some of our values like transparency
and kind of community orientation
and that worked so incredibly well um
so yeah it was working with a small team
to build the brand build the product
get into users hands really quickly and
then see them enjoy it i've talked about
this a lot before that feeling of
um standing in line at a coffee shop and
seeing the person at the counter paying
with a the hot coral monzo card
and then having the bartender or the the
server say you know i've got one of
those as well
and then listening to that conversation
as sort of an anonymous bystander
that's just incredibly rewarding feeling
that you've had a hand in
in creating something that's that people
are enjoying so much
let's dig into the point about brand
then marketing because monzo really was
a uk stand-up brand i think everybody
knew it
um even if they didn't use it because of
its
disruptive values because of it it felt
unconventional in everything it did i
mean even the card
was completely unconventional
intentionally yeah tell me
tell me what the secret was to monzo's
branding success
um for authenticity i think
um it was
we had a couple of early marketing hires
who who didn't work out
um and they were very senior people from
very very big companies who came in
and they were a lot older and cayman is
sort of like you know
how the kids going to think about this
and we were like we are the kids
um so we had a very early community
manager called tristan thomas who was
there from almost
in the first few months uh he just very
recently left to start his own company
and he's now he was a vp of of um
marketing running a massive team with a
massive budget by the end
but he was a 23 year old when he started
you know 23 24 year old
um and i worked on it a lot hugo our
head of design worked on a lot and it
was
um it was just an authentic
representation of i think
who we were and what we believed more
than anything and we we did want to
be different from the big banks we
intentionally positioned ourselves as a
part
so the hot roll card every other bank
was you know blue or purple or
kind of a shade of black basically so
like how far come from that can we get
and the big banks were very impersonal
you know you you never felt like you
were talking to a human and so we
everything we did was human and
transparent
um we we shared a lot of internal
information that everyone you know we
published our product roadmap
this is what we're going to be working
on for the next two years which people
thought were with bonkers but it
that was a way of building trust and
humanity in opposition to these big sort
of faceless banks
um these all sound like first principles
yeah
i mean none of tristan had never worked
in marketing before
his previous job was at a refugee camp
in in the middle east
i'd never really worked in marketing i'd
spent nine months at a dating site but
we
yeah we um we came up we thought about
these principles
and it felt like the kind of company we
wanted to run and so
um we did and it worked really well um
yeah with without any experience it goes
to show the risk of reading marketing
books
no genuinely i've always thought this
because i've never studied marketing or
did any degree
you know our business was did really
well in in the marketing industry but i
think it did well because we hadn't
read those books and we hadn't been sort
of diluted or polluted by conventions
idea of how
yeah i think this today when i go when i
work and go into these family offices
and i'm
working on the marketing plan that the
ceo often
will want to hire someone who's done
marketing in that industry for 20 years
and you immediately feel that that's the
fastest route to not standing out at all
and not having any point of difference
yeah yeah it depends what you want to
achieve if you are a family office or if
you're managing the wealth of
you know generational rich families then
perhaps you do want to
look trustworthy in like everyone else
if you're a challenger bank appealing to
21 to 25 year olds maybe you want a
different approach i don't think there's
a right
answer but i think authenticity gets you
a really really long way
whoever your target demographic is i am
one of the things so we talked a little
bit there about the your best times at
monzo and i wasn't
surprised to hear that it was when the
company was small um because i've
heard that before but i also understand
the feeling um and your worst times
um least enjoyable times least enjoyable
uh i never liked fundraising we did that
a lot
i mean i and i had to i think monzo's
raised something like 600 million and
i probably did 400 of that um that was
always tough
uh and you only hear about the really
quick round though you know the ad
funding
yeah we hit a billion the round where we
hit a billion valuation was very very
fast
um and very competitive so it was that
easy but all the other rounds were real
slog so fundraising was never fun
we had a weird time with the press where
they spent the first three or four years
almost not idolizing us but certainly
building us up you know the new kind of
uh the the sort of next great hope
almost um
and we could almost do nothing wrong
which is not healthy and then we got big
enough and it flipped overnight and just
everything we did was we'd get like
vitriol for in a way that i i mean i can
understand it because it drives
readership right and it's um there's a
point in time where
the telegraph would put monzo in the
headline
at least every day even if it was a
story about one of our competitors it
would be
monzo competitor blah doing just like
what
why and i i eventually sort of called
out the journalists on this and
took him for a beer and it's like look
come on tell me what's going on and he's
like look
every time i put your name in the
headline or rather he's like look it's
my subs who do i
i write the article they choose the
headline um or my editor
but every time they do that we just get
way more subscribers
it's like you know sorry um but it
it was really the entire from the bbc to
the telegraph to everyone
it felt like a pile on in a way that
didn't seem
fair uh really and it's i'm not to say
that we never did anything wrong we
absolutely did but even the good stuff
we did
got um got negative headlines um and i
think that's a peculiarity of the
british press in particular sort of
building something up until it's like
big enough to tear down
and that was just so confusing um
yeah that was tough at one point we had
a bbc camera crew
outside our office um and this was when
we
we'd grown big enough we had um a small
a small minority
of people using monzo for financial
crime basically with money laundering
for
scams um and we'd have to freeze their
account and we
weren't allowed to tell them why we'd
froze in their account we'd sort of send
the money back to where
where wherever it had come from was a
very frustrating experience really and
it's
quite strict in the law that you have to
shut the account you can't tell a person
so it's
it's a really bad customer experience um
but watchdog were running
a program about this you know monzo
freezes accounts
and they brought us a series of accounts
that we'd frozen
um over a series of several weeks saying
you know this is
we've got you and we sort of brought the
editor of the program and said look here
is the
here's the criminal background of the
person whose account we've frozen
are you you're really going to run a
program about about this
it's like oh no okay okay okay this
happened 12 times
and every every one of the times we
showed we the evidence and like okay
you know and on the it was the 13th or
14th like
that was a 50 50. you know we block the
account we stand by it but
we don't have cast iron proofing like
great we've got you so bbc camera crew
turns up
and they'd commissioned a block of ice
an enormous ice sculpture with a frozen
monzo card in the ice that they dumped
outside our office
and put a camera crew there for the day
uh to see if they could find anyone
walking past it or
you know to watch the thing melting
which was like
what's going on you know i was like i
started this company to try and sort of
build a better bank and somehow
the bbc is camped outside my office
trying to like
i don't know i don't know what they're
trying to do um drive
drive viewership um but that was deeply
annoying
this whole press thing is i've heard
this a million times and it terrifies
the [ __ ] out of me because
you know joining dragonstone you join i
was like oh my god amazing
and then someone told me i think it
might be one of the other dragons that's
been there for nearly two decades said
here's what's here's what here's what's
gonna happen is they're going to build
you up
to a point where you're interesting
enough to tear down again and
hearing you say the same thing terrifies
the life out of me and it happens in
everything tech startups um facebook
uh yeah i mean facebook's a great
example of it but it happens to sports
stars it happens to politicians it
happens to
you know singers yeah yeah what advice
would you give
someone that's don't read the good stuff
or the you know
just ignore it all basically i think
it's all yeah just ignore it all
the hype and yeah because when they're
good when they're writing good stuff
that's
that's overblown as well that's not real
life the bad stuff's also not true so
just
i just ignore it all and did that have
an impact on your mental health the
worst parts of the press coverage
it didn't help and i stopped reading it
you know i genuinely stopped reading it
and i'd have friends
sort of come and say it you know on a
saturday or sunday they'd read the
weekend papers and it's like are you all
right it's like i'm fine
what have i done that's the worst
because then you've got to justify to
people you care about
yeah and make them not care like i'm
fine
like okay just don't read the times this
weekend it's like yeah never read the
times
um that was annoying but i don't know
so yeah the um the press was not fun
um investment's not fun regulation got
really really tough
by the end because we were a bank and
ultimately if we fail
the government has to step in and refund
everyone their money so the rules there
were very very strict and because we got
so big
so early and weren't profitable that
that got quite tough
um and i'm going to go through a list of
the bad things now the f
i will stop on the final one which was
um just organizational politics when you
get to we were almost 2 000 people
and when you're 100 or 200 people you
can know everyone and you can
you develop a really close culture
really a sense of team spirit you know
everyone you can know everyone's names
um you get to 2000 people and you don't
and it
um you get subcultures so teams develop
their own sort of internal
narrative as to why they exist and what
they're for and
sometimes like we're saving the company
from this other team over there and it's
you know becomes
um really not collaborative actually and
you get
uh especially with some sort of quite
senior people
start building their little fifedems
and you get this just weird politics and
rivalries going on that
i'd never worked in the company for it's
like total it was totally uh
new to me um especially when you're this
is unfair not everyone
but sometimes when you hire people from
big banks they've grown up with that um
uh culture toxic culture frankly
um and they bring it to a place like
monzo and everyone's
like what that what's weird what's going
on here
but it definitely changed um and that
was
having to deal with that was was tricky
you talked about not being profitable
i've heard you talk about you know that
being one of the um
probably in hindsight one of the things
you should have thought about more in
the early days which was like the
commercial model or the business model
of the bank yep is that
fair yeah absolutely yeah um and we
thought about it for sure
i think what we didn't do was make the
hard decisions to
uh to turn the corner earlier like we
thought about it and it was this was not
it's not like we um blindly ran into
unprofitability we took a series of
actions we knew they were
loss making but we um did that in order
to
to acquire users without paying so
basically we
swapped marketing spec we had no
marketing spend but instead we ran
um uh like like operational losses
so we'd give away features to customers
that would cost us money to get more
customers
because it meant our marketing budget
was zero and we grew to five or six
million people
with we probably spent less than 10
million on marketing total
that's an average cost per customer of
one pound 50. great
right so um but that that's
that hides operational losses that's our
real marketing budget was giving away
things like
html withdrawals for free for example
and we just didn't take the hard
decisions to turn some of those things
off when we
um we got to a certain size and it cost
us way too much
free cards yeah expensive
with that it's like the long tail it's
you know it's the um
the very small number of people who are
ordering 20 or 30 cards a year
most people they order zero to one
that's fine but
some people just lose their card every
weekend and they get struggled no
problem just order another one it'll be
here tomorrow morning
uh and that's just annoying and costly
the other thing though
um so we should have paid more attention
to reducing costs and
taking a hard decision to drive revenues
earlier uh we consciously didn't
but part of it was avoiding those hard
decisions the other half of it though
is weird um
i've thought about it a lot it's
basically how you get
almost self-reinforcement from your
investors so you run a business a
certain way
you get to a certain scale and you
present it to a set of investors
and the ones who are more or less the
ones who agree with what you've done and
think it's the right approach we'll
invest
and the ones who think you're bonkers
will not invest and they'll go to
someone else
the problem is that becomes
self-reinforcing because they like what
you did before so like yeah just do more
of that
and it can become um a bit of an echo
chamber where you just get the group of
investors around the table who are all
big supporters who all really believe in
the model
and there's not really anyone being like
uh you know you're running
um you should really think about this
other stuff
and a really a really smart thing i've
heard
which i didn't do and i i hope i will
will have the humility to do in future
is to sort of
pick out the smartest investors you can
or smarter's advisors or other other
founders
and ask them why you think your business
will fail
and then really try to think deeply
about that rather than
i think the natural tendency is just
like ah you know whatever they don't
know what they're talking about i'll
just
the people who think i'm brilliant i'll
listen to them um
but that can become i don't think you
grow as much from that so
really finding the doubters even the not
so much the haters but the doubt is
certainly
and interrogating them about your
business and really trying to think
through how you can
solve those problems i think that would
have helped us a lot
hindsight's a wonderful thing yeah now
you have those
some of those answers in hindsight and
what were
what are those answers in hindsight that
you wish you'd um
you'd known sooner so one of them's
obviously you know getting to a
profitable business model sooner making
those transitions
profitable business model um cutting
costs driving revenue by taking hard
decisions to sort of limit some of the
free features and charges some of the
things we gave for free i think she'd
done that way way earlier
um that's the biggest any cultural
decisions i knew there was a
merging of the startup guys and the uh
banking
people which i guess that's necessary
right yeah
i struggled to get the banking license
without that and you've seen you can see
that at revolut
you look at all their recent senior
highs over the last year or two and it's
big wigs from the big banks because
they're trying to get a banking licence
so
i think that's sort of inevitable um and
you pay a cost for that you pay the
price
um customer service is always
one of big one of our uh investors who
shall name
remain nameless um was a bit of
contrarians basically said
the quality of your customer service is
too high
and it's costing you too much and it's
going to be the you know it's going to
be the weight around your neck for the
next
whatever 10 years until you can slash
and i'm not sure if he was right or not
actually
um that's when i still debate um i've
noticed revel
revolute's uh customer service has
declined
month almost month over month for the
last two years i've been a customer
there on
monday but revolut they've made a real
significant
it feels like effort to either cut back
on customer service costs or
just because they've got more users
they're struggling yeah but i've from
when i joined revolu it was just
amazing yep and two years almost three
years on
it's just awful yeah and i think monzo's
hopefully it's not awful but i think it
was amazing
at the start and i think it's now
variable
i think sometimes it's really really
great but sometimes you end up waiting a
little too long
sometimes it's a little too hard to talk
to a customer service agent arguably
i think i still think it's pretty good
but in the early days it was spectacular
it was the number one thing our
customers talked about was the service
by far you'd look on social media
whatever it was just
and if we'd have the revenue to support
that i think we could have continued
it's not
it's not very expensive it cost us about
12 or 13 pounds per customer per year to
provide that
and i think the benchmark that
everyone's aiming for is less than that
clearly
and so the drive is always to automate
more to put you know
chatbots in to do whatever there comes a
point in your journey with monzo where
you realize that
you're no longer enjoying it for me in
my business
it was kind of like a there wasn't a
point it wasn't a day when i woke up it
was kind of a
compounding of several issues that
slowly wore me down
yes uh uh yes it was that plus covered
and covered it was like knockout punch
but yeah it was
four or five four five six issues that
meant for the last
year or two i wasn't having a good time
really and i talked to my board about it
i talked to investors about i think
hiring really good senior leaders
was part of the potential solution and
we
didn't do that fast enough um we've got
some great great senior leaders in now
um and i sort of wonder what would have
happened if we could have got those
people in a year or two earlier
um possibly they wouldn't we wouldn't
pay them enough they wouldn't have
joined
um i did talk about this a ts our new
ceos like
if you'd have come five years ago i
would have joined five years ago i was
like
go back in time um uh but yeah it was
four five six issues and then covered
and that was just
i mean for so many people in the world
that was horrific for us our revenue
declined at least 50 percent
within about a week or so uh the cost
base was the same revenue goes down 50
we were already lost making so now it's
sort of
we had a funding we had 100 million
funding round lined up
to close on the monday and on friday
before london went to lockdown and all
the terms she's got pulled
so again retrospects uh hindsight is
2020.
um everything has bounced back
even like the in the investment market
private investment and public
investments
are stronger than it was pre-covet and
so people just take these really
short-term decisions in a
kind of in a shock in a crisis destroy a
ton of value for themselves
um and you know six nine 12 months later
everything's bounced back even harder i
just don't understand it
um but anyway covid was definitely the
straw that broke the camel's back
and about six weeks into that six to
eight weeks which is like i'm
i'm working seven days a week i'm not
sleeping here this is just
you know i need sort of throw the towel
in almost you know i need to i need to
be subbed out
had you been thinking about that
conversation for some time before you
got to the point where you
you approached the board with the
decisiveness that this has been done
i'm not even thinking about i've been
talking to them about it for a year or
two yeah
not the whole board but yeah two members
our chairman and uh
one of our lead investors absolutely
we'd we'd had multiple conversations
about
me not enjoying the role as it was then
configured and the answer was like okay
let's reconfigure a role let's
bring people around you let's because
because we're growing so quickly and the
way that senior hiring works
by the time you realize you've got a gap
it's 12 to 18 months
before you can actually fill that gap
and you know muggins here ends up
doing to be fair all of my senior team
were doing
more than one job trying to fill the
gaps but um
that was the biggest problem for me that
we didn't have
the right senior leadership in place so
i was working several jobs
uh and so the conversation was always
okay well we'll fill these roles we'll
fill these roles
but by the time you filled that role
this other role over there the person
who's doing really well at 200
you're now 2000 people and the person's
burnt out or
you know not doing well and you have to
replace them and so
it was like whack-a-mole
[Music]
and i think that was the biggest
contributing factor but those are
conversations i very regularly had with
um board members and investors do you
think those conversations were treated
with
with urgency no from from
either yourself or the board no
absolutely not
it was always like oh yeah oh yeah we'll
just hire you know we'll hire the person
it'll
be fine or i'll just stick it out for
another couple of years
and it'll all be fine and eventually
it's like no i've got a couple of weeks
yeah i think a lot of them did
a huge amount i mean eileen the one of
our investors from passion
personally put in so much time to
support the company and support me and
i'm
really really grateful for that
but ultimately um yeah we just didn't
hire
see great senior people fast enough that
if i can find one root cause it was that
do you think if you'd gone to the board
with more urgency and decisiveness
yourself
though you would have been taken more
seriously
if you said listen i'm going to go next
week
if these issues aren't fixed because i
i'm asking these questions
from same reasons as uh i said before i
went through the same thing where i
approached the board i said i've got
some problems here
these are the issues can we fix them and
it was probably a little bit of lip
service
yeah until the day that i resigned yeah
i don't know i think a lot of people put
a lot of effort into fixing it
ultimately was like on me to fix
no one else is going to come in and hire
a really top senior team for me it's
that's sort of
my job um
[Music]
so i don't know i also i do wonder
whether you really could have got those
great senior people in at a
earlier stage the analogy's sort of like
a football team you're starting in the
i don't know what the fourth division
now is cool but you know you're there
and you get promoted
and you want to hire someone for the
third division but everyone's like oh go
and hire ronald it's like ronaldo is not
coming to play
for a third division team you know so
it's a constant process of upgra like
gradually upgrading until you get into
premiership
um and even then you know you're you're
charleston athletic or something
uh so i just think it's tough i don't i
don't
think there's a magic bullet actually a
quick one since leaving social chain a
couple years ago as you probably know
i've kept my options open
i've worked in a series of companies as
a consultant as a creative director as
an advisor
as an investor but i've kept my options
open and that is about to change because
i'm about to embark on my next chapter
building my next company and i'm going
to tell you guys about it first but i
wanted to talk about something related
to that
when i'm building this new company as i
have been over the last three months
we need everything from websites to
logos to
editing work done to some sort of admin
stuff done
and it's crazy that even me even though
i have
a lot of financial resources i still
turn to fiverr.comfiveerr.com
to help me with freelance services for
me it is a godsend
if you're scaling your business if
you're looking to start a project or
you're developing yours
try fiverr.com if you go to f i v
e r r dot com slash ceo
pick a service try it and then send me a
message and let me know how you found it
i'm gonna be paying for five people to
have their services done on fiverr.com
so go to that website now links in the
bio and let me know what you think
you said you weren't sleeping working
seven days a week talk me
through those moments when you when
things were
have you experienced that i've oh
definitely experienced
um anxiety and not sleeping well
and an issue usually like payroll or
some kind of investor issue
plaguing me for days and days and then
getting sick yeah and
why have i got a cold i never get it
cold and then yeah oh of course because
there's no [ __ ] money in the bank or
something
yeah um similar things uh
we talked about a little earlier sort of
that depletion of emotional energy so
that you
have a you know there's a sort of a
problem there you need to make a
decision about maybe it's like one of
your senior teams not working out you
know you have to
fire them basically but like if i do
that that's going to cause a bunch of
other knock-on problems i don't want to
deal with yet because i'm i'm just
trying to close this like 100 million
pound funding round
so just let me focus on that and and the
um
the realization was sort of when the
round closes when the money's in the
bank and that weight lifts
you then look at all these other
problems and they're very very easy
actually like you
re-energize quite quickly and able to
take those decisions but while there's
just too many things sort of resting on
your shoulders you
it piles up and piles up and piles up
and so for me yeah it was
um waking up at sort of four or five in
the morning
often with um often with problems in the
cold light of day are
relatively easy to solve but this the
conscious part of your mind gets turned
off when you're sleeping it's a sort of
subconscious
like irrational part that blows the
thing into a
unsolvable problem and the next more you
can whatever you write it down you come
back to the next day and go that
that's ridiculous why am i even worrying
about that
um so it's not a rational thing it's a
much more of an emotional
um at least for me emotional response
but because you're tired you make worse
decisions and because you make worse
decisions
you end up creating more problems to
yourself um
you know and the solution is easy to say
and hard to do which is
exercise more and you know stay off
alcohol
and get to bed early and don't have your
phone in your bedroom and like
turn off your computer at the weekends
all this sort of stuff you know you
should do
um but when each one gives way the next
one's harder you know
you haven't slept well so you don't want
to go to the gym in the morning and
because you look at the gym
you blah blah blah blah blah so you can
either get into i think really good
reinforcing cycles or very destructive
kind of negatively reinforcing cycles
because you knew your mind was going to
do that when you fell asleep did you
upon getting in bed and laying down
presumably you knew that your mind was
then going to run off with all of the
thoughts and worries did that make that
process just before you fall asleep
quite unpleasant yes and you sort of
going to sleep
almost inevitably knowing you're going
to wake up at 4 am
is quite annoying to say the least
and the
it's a very depressing thing to say but
sometimes when i did sleep a sort of
full night i'd wake up at 7 8 9 a.m
whatever
and for about three or four seconds
i'd forgotten what my life was like i'd
forgotten
what i was doing what my job was all the
pressures and i was like i was calm
and i was sort of you know not stressed
not anxious and then
three or four seconds later all the
memories came back it was just like this
crushing weight
that that feeling was just terrible and
that
really was the moment i just sort of
knew this is this is no life you know i
want the
life three seconds ago where i can wake
up and not be worried and not be
stressed and not feel like
just anxious the whole time like there
would there were no other emotions in my
life really apart from just anxiety
that was a ten out of ten and every
other emotion felt like it's a the
volume had been switched down to one out
of ten because like anxiety was just 10
out of 10.
and that was no fun how long did that
last
a year and a half two years maybe [ __ ]
you know
god i can imagine two years not fun and
i split up with my girlfriend as a
result of it it's like mate you know
my life's [ __ ] what can i do about it
let's like one by one try and change
things
um and rather than changing the job
first i changed a girlfriend first
um and that was really tough um
[Music]
i left monzo and within about a week or
so i was sleeping
perfectly through the night and it
really just all went away
yeah and now i you know i am
uh i hesitate to use the word happy but
yeah i happy like
content calm relaxed like i find things
to do
with my day that i find you know that i
enjoy
and and suddenly like the small those
like emotions that were one out of ten
when they're not being crushed by a ten
out of ten anxiety like sort of start to
bloom back which is cool which um i like
this is life yeah yeah
the girlfriend topic i find compelling
because i
i've also struggled in that department
forever yeah um
how was it trying to hold down a
relationship whilst also
this business just being this crushing
force in your life
terrible uh and i really um
uh we we're um good friends still
but she was a lovely kind considerate
person
and i was just not a nice person to be
around a lot of the time
just like really um short-tempered
like inconsiderate and like intolerant
basically intolerant
there's something that was like tiny
tiny things that a normal person would
just be like that's
just a cute quirk i feel like that's so
irritating you know
um and so we just ended up not enjoying
spending time together
sadly um and i i think she was doing a
lot
to try and you know make our lives
together
wonderful and i was just a monster
because my
primarily because my work was so [ __ ] um
which i regret a lot
it's interesting so when um what i
noticed about myself is when i had a
girlfriend
at the height of my uh ceo [ __ ]
um i would make her feel incredibly
lonely
even if i sat next to her because i you
know i was selfish and self-absorbed and
i did wasn't interested in anything but
my own problems and
i also didn't particularly want to talk
to her about them because that was just
i felt like it would grow the problem if
i then went home and just
brain dumped on her yep um yeah
do you think it's possible for a ceo
that's in a high intensity situation to
have a successful early-stage
relationship
i mean i never managed but i believe it
is possible i've seen other people do it
and then
i think um part of it is maturity
and um uh
detachment but not in a bad way and i
mean detachment from your job
being able to compartmentalize so paul
one of my co-founders a little bit older
um and i think he had a really great
ability to sort of
come to work and be fully present in
work and then to go home and just
totally switch it off
as soon as his head hit the pillow he
was asleep he had
he and his wife run a lovely alpaca farm
in the north of england
and he was just really good at having
sort of of
compartmentalizing his life i think
similarly with ts the new um
the new ceo at monso he's an older guy
um i think he's in his 50s and has run
big banks before and is
you know finds it challenging and
exciting and a little stressful but i
think he's able to go back to his family
and sort of switch that part of his
brain off and i could never do that i
it was all-consuming uh sort of
emotionally that
i would never even on holiday i could
never
switch off the nagging feeling about the
work
um so towards the end there was a little
bit more detachment and talking to jonas
my co-founder as well i think
he took everything so personally in the
early days and
sort of six seven years in you you
there's a bit of detachment
um and i think that's actually really
healthy to realize that your
entire person is not intrinsically
linked to this company and you can leave
and the company will continue and
maybe the company fails and you'll still
survive and that's sort of um
by the way i think monzo's doing
incredibly well it's not going to fail
um
but just that emotional realization that
you're not like the same being
as your company uh would have been
helpful earlier on
i heard you had a red phone in your
bedroom or something is that true yes
why was it red um
it was more like a sort of um childish
pink color actually right
the red pho is probably a dramatization
i think i described as a red phone it
was a pink it was an old nokia
um uh and why
so the reason why um is first of all
because
to help sleep i didn't keep my own
mobile in my bedroom
so i turned it off and i had it charging
out the hallway which i think is i
encourage everyone to do i think it's
great because you know
the first thing i used to do when i wake
up and sometimes i do it still it's like
you grab the phone and start
and that's just not healthy so not
having the phone
in your eye lasting at night not having
the first in the morning just charge it
in another room
um that is a great step unfortunately
when
there are really significant problems at
three or four in the morning and
it doesn't happen often but you know it
happened occasionally you need to be
able to wake the senior management team
up and the ceo up
to make the hard calls um and so that
phone was like the back phone if
something went wrong
that would be the only one in my room
the only
no one had the number it was linked to
our automatic alerting system so if
at monzo if something went wrong you
sort of click a button it would escalate
and if it got escalated far enough the
ceo gets woken up
but only that system had the phone
number this and so if it rang
it was because the bank was down um
and that happened a handful of times not
you know not every week but
every two or three months sometimes um
what an awful phone call yeah oh yeah
yeah
and it wasn't a person it was a you know
it's a robot saying like wake up
there's an incident you are required to
blah blah blah it's like ugh
yeah that it's horrible because you can
see your hand gesture then
how it felt yeah the heart your heart
drops and you know it's going to be
the rest of your week if not your month
is going to be ruined and it's
you don't know if this is like the one
that's going to kill the company we had
a few like that it's like
you know it's is i think a lot of
founders have like those moments like
oh [ __ ] is you know is this it is this
the moment the company dies
um and there's often not a lot you can
do actually as a
you know your engineers running around
trying to fix a problem
and you getting stuck in is not going to
help help things so you're sort of
almost like a helpless
sideline observer um you know you have
to make the phone call to the board and
to the investors and
sometimes to the regulators at four in
the morning um
but yeah you're in a pretty helpless
situation
yes there was a red phone it was more
like a pink nokia okay but it sounds
better
it sounds way better in the movie it'll
definitely be a red phone yeah
um it'll be in like a box with like a
maybe a code on it
um i find that what you just said
they're really interesting so there's
because i've been through that those key
moments where you're not sure if your
company is going to survive
and it feels like the answer or the
determinant factor
is actually outside of your control yep
so it's someone else's decision whether
your company
survives yep did you have many moments
like that where it felt like it was
someone else's decision if your company
was going to survive
an investor or yeah and not loads but a
handful
so early investment rounds um
it was binary if we don't raise the
money we we're folding
the later rounds are more like the
money's going to come in at some
evaluation
um uh or some early outages we had a
really very bad we were still a prepaid
card at the time and one of our
suppliers
which connected us to the mastercard
network
went down it really went down hard for
about 10 or 11 hours
we didn't know it was going to be 10 or
11 hours it just was down and we phoned
them up and they were panicking
and didn't have a they didn't know when
it's going to be back and so
you know we had about 300 000 cars at
the time sort of like
this could be two months like all the
cars could not work for two months now
or rather it would take us two months to
rebuild this thing
um and that yeah we're just sitting
there thinking this is
we it's our fault in the sense that we
picked the supplier but beyond that like
they've just [ __ ] up right then you
know i it
it was it was totally ridiculous what
had happened in retrospect
but um yeah that was uh real like
we can't do anything we literally yeah
we're sitting there on customer support
the entire company
we pulled in on a sunday to respond to
all the customers and to proactively
learn all this good stuff
but that was a sort of we don't know if
this is even gonna come back online
outside of the business and the chaos of
the business what was your life
at that point um
fairly normal
um we had a pretty good culture
around sort of work-life balance at
monzo um
you know mostly i was working five days
a week unless we were fundraising i
guess and
i traveled probably a week every month
mostly for fundraising
but i had a really close group of
friends mostly from
you know growing up mostly from my
secondary school actually
i lived with my girlfriend we live you
know we lived in a big house with
friends we cooked a lot
um i took up pottery i i exercised a
fair amount it was very very normal
not really nothing extraordinary but i
wasn't working 100 hours a week for sure
i was doing 45 50 55 hours
um really not a the time pressure was
not the problem it was the mental like
the mental load the inability to switch
off outside those hours and then boom
pandemic
yeah comes around term sheets get pulled
yeah you're sat there you've already you
know it's by the sounds of it you're
already on the verge of
well you already weren't happy with how
things were going and then that's the i
guess the straw that broke the camel's
back
for sure when you realized that you were
going to depart
and you knew there was a date you knew
people were gonna know
you knew was going to come out in the
press what were the range of emotions
and were sadness one of them yeah
definitely
um 80 was just like i can breathe again
so it was overwhelmingly positive for me
i and i'm not afraid to say that um
and so i don't want to build it up and
you know it's a sort of negative
thing really but there were 20 things
like
sadness that i was leaving a team
that i really really liked
overwhelmingly um
guilt that i'd recruited many of these
people and some of them had joined to
come and work with me
um and that i was leaving them to kind
of fix the mess
um yeah
guilt i think was more than sadness
were there tears shed um
i cry quite a lot
i cried as well when i i went through a
range of emotions my first one was i was
angry a little bit because
as i said i'd been given a lot i felt
what felt like lip service yeah so i was
annoyed at first but then when i
realized that i was actually gonna send
the email
yeah it was like gratitude yeah and
some kind of like sad or happy tears yep
um i uh so i did an all hands i
announced it at a on a video call with
like 1500 people or something
and i definitely welled up at one or two
points there um
in a in a genuine way but um
what i have learnt over the last few
years is that
um vulnerability is the best way to
inspire
is confidence trust sort of become a
leader
to show if it's genuine you know you
can't sort of
you know the fake tears but genuinely
like
showing your emotion and showing your
vulnerability and showing your
screw-ups is such a powerful way
to inspire followership um and so what
it doesn't i wasn't
i wasn't afraid of that or embarrassed
by you know i was sort of welling up on
a call with 1500 people
but it wasn't the first time i'd like
practically cried in front of the
company
um you know i'm not ashamed of that so
and then the uh the weightlifting
yeah great
no one can [ __ ] email you and you
know um it was great actually it wasn't
it was great but then we were in the
midst of a lockdown
and i was my house was having building
work done
so i had to get out of my house with
four housemates
we went to a farmhouse in devon
which was idyllic but everyone else was
working
i had no job it was in the middle of
nowhere
it was pretty boring actually for quite
a while i think if you know if london
had been booming and i could kind of go
out and meet people have fun it would
have been a great experience but
actually
that's um especially uh if remember sort
of thinking back to april may
of last year when everything was really
hard to lock down still
april may 2020 not a fun experience
really i think i am an
extrovert um i thought i thought about
this a lot i really i get energy from
being around people
and i was with four people just working
all the time and um in the middle of
rural devon
yeah not fun but i mean it's a lot to go
from
having such an intense overwhelming
purpose
and sense of mission every day to having
pretty much none yeah and waking up in
the morning and thinking
what am i going to do today what happens
today it's weird because my time was
especially monday to friday was
scheduled from sort of nine
nine am till about seven or eight pm was
scheduled down to the
down to five minutes easily um and you'd
look at my diary they would
you wouldn't find more than five minutes
spare sort of in that block
so yes having nothing to do was uh kind
of weird and so i
you know i wrote a list of all the
things i wanted to do i actually had
this list for five or six years
so i started looking down the list for
things i could do whilst in lockdown
um many of the things i couldn't yet do
so i started drawing
i spent two or three months drawing i
saw that um
hockney had started using his ipad so i
started drawing on my ipad
which i i only kept up for about a month
or two um
but learning a language was on the list
i bought some kite surfing gear and did
a load of coat surfing which was amazing
now um i'm training up to um
a big offshore sailing race so kind of a
yacht race called fastnet
uh so that's in august i'm learning to
fly so i have a list
so now my time is not as planned but
it's still and
i'm spending a couple of days a week
vaccinating people which is um
which is very rewarding um so i'm busy
again but each of it is like
not inconsequential i think the
vaccination service is a great thing to
do but
if i wasn't there there would be someone
else there you know doing the jabbing
um so each one i could sort of walk away
from pretty easily
so it's a it's busy but it's low low
pressure i guess yeah
and it seems like you're focusing on
things that give you like an
intrinsic joy yeah and learning i really
like learning
um any really anything so the process of
going from a
complete novice to someone you know
mediocre
uh i love and i'm angel investing that's
to keep a connection to the tech
community i'm
i've made seven or eight investments in
the first half of 2021
i'll probably make another seven or
eight towards the end of the year and
i'm helping out a few of
or at least i'm going in to bother the
founders whether i'm helping or not i
don't know
[Music]
it feels like a job where you have to
pay to go to work you know
um but i like that a lot uh
me and my co-founder went on felt two
very different things when we departed
we departed at the same time pretty much
and um
he because he didn't have anything to do
um upon departing i think he struggled
quite significantly
you kind of lose the orientation in your
life and yeah you're right when your
schedule you're so used to your schedule
running your life when there's nothing
there
you get out of bed a bit later and then
you you know you can
that's that sense of lacking purpose you
see it within olympic athletes like
michael phelps when he wins all the gold
medals and then
comes home they call it gold medal
depression and you don't have that
thing you're striving towards or for
that meaningful goal
life can seem to lose orientation a
little bit your schedule now is as busy
now as it was
when you were working no no i mean the
dragon's done thing is as
and maybe maybe brought it close
because it's like 7am and i get home at
midnight yeah but um
dragons then aside no and i've also i
mean there's nothing
there isn't huge stakes so even the work
that i do do the things that are in my
schedule i can just cancel if i don't
want to do it whereas before it was huge
stakes i had to get on the flight yeah
or i had to be up at 4am so you know so
but but you know both you and me that
there's still going to be that yearning
to
go back no
do you think you'll ever go back to
starting a company being the ceo
i don't know i have thought about this a
lot and people have asked me uh and i
don't know
um the thought process goes something
like um
i love the early stage so you get a few
of your mates together
people you've always wanted to work with
perhaps and you start something
and one of two things happens
you fail and that you know now you're
kind of relatively high profile founder
who's on to his third thing the third
thing's flopped and like ah we all knew
he's an idiot so like okay that's
humiliating
or it's a success and you grow and
become a two thousand person company and
you're like
why have i done this to myself again i
hate running two thousand person
companies
um so the out i like the
journey bit but the outcome either end
don't lose lose yeah like it doesn't
seem there's much upside i mean
it it's financially like very
remunerative if you do well but
um it doesn't make my life happier so
so in that sense no um with some caveats
one thing i've thought about doing which
i've
i've not started yet really is kind of
run a studio so you get
four or five mates together with the aim
of coming up with an idea
putting in a ceo or a founder a
management team and kind of
incubating it for properly incubating
for 12 months you know actually like
building the first version and doing the
marketing and but once it's at 12 or 18
months putting a full management team in
sort of
letting it go you know so you retain a
minority equity stake but really it's
the
the ceo and the management team that's
that's owning and running it so you
you're able to that first year but then
you're like hands off and then doing
that every year for five or six years so
you end up with a portfolio of i don't
know six to ten companies
so i thought about that a bit seems like
a lot of hard work um
so i haven't done it yet but i might do
that i think you'd probably end up
getting sucked into the same problems
yeah i agree because i think the power
law distribution of startup success
means that one
if you are successful one of the ten
will be incredibly successful and then
they'll be like oh you know the ceo's
not quite doing as well as i would have
liked and
you know either you think you should go
in or someone else thinks you should go
in and you're ultimately
you're running a 2000 company again and
that's the thing i'm trying to avoid
um because i know a guy that does that
how's that going
um yes but he hasn't avoided the
[ __ ] so he's what he's
he's a billionaire he's a
multi-billionaire um and he
says oh i'm not g he when when press
asks him he goes oh yeah i'm just not
good at the operational bit i know what
he means is
because i've spoken to him privately he
doesn't want to do the operational bit
doesn't want to care about people's
birthdays that's what he says i don't
want to have to
think about people's birthdays right so
what he does is he comes he'll
have a passion in his life say
psychedelics yep
and he'll go and assemble a team a ceo
co-founding team he'll go and hire the
people and then he'll handle the
fundraising piece yep and he'll go off
you go
company but i still know that when [ __ ]
hits the fan
and they've got funding issues yeah
because he is the
the big name in the piece he'll be front
and center of trying to solve those
problems
um i i i he lives a much better life
than i think the ceo would
yeah and i think that's fine like i
wouldn't i'm not looking for a zero
stress life
um but i think yeah a lot of the people
[ __ ] i don't like
um the fun fundraising isn't fun but i
i think i have done it enough now that i
could do it again in a relatively
stress-free way
but at 2000 people it's
not even remembering people's birthdays
right right in the calendar like that's
not
you know i had a great assistant who
would help me with a lot of that stuff
like
it doesn't come naturally to me it's
more like
you know there's someone misbehaving
like 2 000 people someone's done
something stupid
at the christmas party and like it
should be the chief people after dealing
with it but
maybe she was misbehaving this never
happened at monzo
but um for some reason it ends up on
your
on your desk like why am i dealing with
these miscreants
like they're [ __ ] around like this is
not like on top of everything i'm doing
i'm having to sort out this hr issue
you have to because it i've been i was
thinking i was just thinking of one
incident at christmas party because you
said christmas party
i'm not going to me and my co-founder
stopped like we would go until 8pm
yeah and then leave you'll be like this
is not because it'd be too much alcohol
yeah and when you're 50 100 people you
know each other so well that like
people i don't know maybe we're just
lucky but people sort of respect
boundaries and behave themselves
two thousand just law of averages like
there's you know one in a thousand
people is gonna do something stupid so
you have two of them
now at two thousand people doing
something stupid every every party it's
like
they're gonna get fired for i know one
incident
well many incidents but i mean the crazy
twists and turns of being the ceo and
finding these things out and we had
someone who had been on doing i think
silk road on the dark where
seven years ago got arrested they'd
worked for me for three and a half years
i thought they were a great guy yeah
they got
sent to jail for seven years like the
nicest guy in the company and he'd done
it when he's a student
all kinds of things christmas parties
someone's pushed someone into the toilet
and kissed them and these are the things
that in fact you do have to make the
call on yep
even though it's such it seems like such
a pathetic thing but that is
sexual assault totally and and you can't
allow an incident like that to be
mis-mishandled right because that is
like that proposes an existential risk
against your company yeah
if that were to break in the press so
yeah and you know and it's
and it's the right thing to do but uh it
should be the chief people off the
handle yeah right like
that's sort of my that was my problem
like there were periods of time when we
didn't have a chief people officer so it
just landed my desk and
i'm fine dealing with a section of those
but when you're dealing with like
four or five people's jobs worth of that
[ __ ] then it gets overwhelming so
yeah i think it always comes back you
have a
incredibly sort of um
successful talented senior team and the
stress becomes left because each
you don't a ceo don't deal with that
your chief people officer says by the
way
this happened and i've dealt with it you
go great oh thank god yeah i love those
people in business
they deal with it and then tell they
come to you with it sometimes but they
tell you they've already dealt with it
yep no action required tom it's already
been solved but just so you're aware
i love these people and that's but
that's how a senior team should work
really um and
at its best it works like that it is
magical death threats
nice little transition though i'd never
got death threats as the ceo of social
chain but i hear that you got a few
uh not loads but yes we and um and
several of our staff as well
um and we've got people turning up to
the office being we had security
full-time security at are office and
still do now
because customs would turn up sometimes
with weapons
um they threatened to turn up with you
know a bottle of acid and their acid in
someone's face
um yeah and yeah and come
you know there were sort of groups on
social media who sort of
try to find our addresses and sort of
hand them around
because i mean with six million
customers again
sort of probabilities if one in a
million is a bad egg you've got six bad
eggs um
because we were a bank we dealt with
people's money and because we had
obligations to
detect and prevent financial crime we
would
um we would detect criminals and shut
their accounts down
and the like the really pro criminals
would just treat it as a cost of doing
business right like
fine we've got thousands of these things
it was like the amateur criminal
who like really thought we had a payday
it's like he scammed some old lady out
of
her retirement you know he's got 20
grand are you like no shutting it down
sorry sending it back and it
got crazy like this was my big payoff
i'm going to come and
[ __ ] you up um and clearly
there were times when we blocked
accounting correctly
if you're blocking tens of thousands of
accounts you absolutely are going to get
it wrong
occasionally and it sometimes it takes
too long to get money back and we work
really hard
to get that time period really really as
quick as possible but
still the law gets in the way you know
you have to report it to the national
crime agency you have to wait for them
to get back to you and it can take four
weeks and they just don't get back to
you so it's like okay we'll give them
the four weeks and then we'll refund you
so there are rare cases where you're
sitting on a legitimate customs money
for four weeks and they're going
ballistic because they can't feed their
kids or whatever
but a lot of the time it's scammer who's
like they would phone up and they would
have a record of a baby playing in the
background
so you know i can't can't feel my baby
yeah yeah
um so yes it was never the professional
criminals
because they just choose a costume
business and by the way there were a ton
of those and we
and we caught way more than our fair
share we were using a lot of
um basic machine learning to track sort
of weird patterns and shutting their
accounts down
we worked very very closely with the
with law enforcement to
to shut a bunch of these things down i'm
some of them were like
wild there was a big ring a couple of
years no probably three or four years
ago now where
um if you've got a fuel pump you can
um you basically put your you sort of
pay at the pump but what it would do is
pre-authorize
a penny on your card you'd pump your
fuel and then it would try and then it
would calculate how much fuel you'd
actually spend and then then take the
payment
so people get a monzo card put one p on
it swipe it
and then go with a modified ford transit
so it's not like a
80 feet of petrol the whole thing was a
fuel tanker
so they'd put 10 grand of petrol into
their ford transit and then just drive
off
and the the payment on the card would
bounce and they'd go and use that
to like they'd sell it to whoever wants
petrol haul is
uh farmers whatever um but they're
basically scamming um
all of these petrol stations uh so we
spotted that pretty quickly
um and shut that down which i'm really
really proud of um
there were several people trafficking
rings where they would
um bring in women from um often east
like east um eastern europe uh and then
traffic them for sex basically
um and you'd spot patterns of behavior
like
patterns of spend which suggests
basically someone is being driven around
in a in an uber or a taxi to um to be
pimped out
um we'd spot that and work with law
enforcement to actually like
um go and rescue people which is amazing
like that's an amazing amazing feeling
um but and those were mostly the pros
who were like meh
you know you got us this time we've got
these other rings so like whatever but
it was mostly the amateur ones who get
really really angry
you know they'd scanned three or four
grand out of someone and
it sounds like a lot to think about tom
yeah there's all of this hidden stuff
you know you know you think of monzo and
it's like the hot cold card and some
great branding
i thought it was just a like nice
colored card oh my god
i mean it was serious by the end like
the running a bank is serious we were
processing
i don't know 100 billion pounds a year
or something of payments like it
this is it's a lot of money it's
people's salaries it's
and you six million customers you see
their whole life you see the great
stuff and you see the terrible stuff um
were you ever scared or threatened
personally did you ever feel
threatened personally in terms of your
personal security
was there ever where you thought you
know actually i do feel about unsafe
here
um i had security and there was a we got
a security firm to come and like look at
my online profile
look at my house and uh figure out how
much of it i was in danger and that was
a bit unsettling
and there were times when especially
when we had customers saying i'm you
know
we know where your office is and you
don't know who i am but i'm going to
come with a bottle of acid i'm going to
throw it in someone's face
so that as you let as we left the office
there was a bit of you know a
little apprehension there certainly um
but
but no in general no it wasn't something
i live with every single day
but um but it was on them on your mind
certainly in a way that i think
most people at most companies thankfully
don't have to deal with that kind of
[ __ ]
but now you're enjoying the small things
in life yeah yeah maybe i should go back
to therapy now and like
you can make it even better yeah there's
small things in life that you're
enjoying
what are they yeah walking in the park i
heard
so uh my housemate's got a dog recently
that's quite fun
um uh a lot of my friends have just had
children
so not me but you know my um i'm
godfather to a couple of young kids my
brother
has a young girl now um a
disproportionate amount of kids
you're you're getting same as me i am
the godfather to all of my friends kids
now
it's uh i'm not sure i have any friends
left really who are not
either parents or trying to become
parents we're you know i'm 35
so it's i'm trying to find new younger
friends now
avoid that stage of my life for another
few years um
yeah i i love pottery i'm learning to
fly i'm sailing
i love to cycle i kite surf a lot of
active outdoorsy stuff
i'm growing plants on my roof my
courgettes have just come out
which is uh yeah they're great what
about
your relationships are you single
taken dating i am dating
uh i've always been um intrigued by
dating apps
i worked at one um i've written about 20
of a book on one wow but over like the
last 12 years
it's not going to get finished so i've
been intrigued by
that sort of whole scene for a while um
yeah and i'm dating and sort of having
fun but i'm not
um
not good at settling down i think or i
don't know maybe i've just not
met the right person to settle down i i
don't know i really
enjoy meeting new people but after six
months or a year or something i'm sort
of like
um
i don't know what it is it's sort of
like deciding to commit to each other
and spend the rest of your life together
i really admire
people who are able to do that because i
have not yet been able to do that
have you managed to analyze where you
think that might come from
like inability to be content this is
what i should go talk to a therapist
about no because i'm asking for myself
i like novelty i really like new things
new experiences and i get bored quite
easily um
[Music]
so i don't know yeah probably i think
combining um uh psychedelics and therapy
to solve this problem
what's my next challenge have you ever
done psychedelics i haven't neither of
us i would love to
i really wish i could say i had i'm
trying to but it's just
finding the right place and time i think
yeah so what's um
so we look forward at the future of your
life
i guess a lot a lot of question marks
you're not really sure which direction
you're going because i think i think you
well i think you you kind of answered
yourself at the start about your
your purpose in life now yeah what your
purpose is i don't have one and i'm
totally fine with that yeah um
i i think looking forward to sort of
when i'm
60 65 um i think i would like a family
around
but i'm not sure i'm willing to make
sacrifices to
put in the hard work to actually make
that happen you know what i mean what
are those sacrifices
like giving up the fun single life like
the
bringing up a baby isn't i've seen it
secondhand you know i'm not doing it day
in day out but it's hard
really and i have huge respect for that
i'm just not sure i'm willing to
sacrifice my freedom and my my total
lack of
like obligation um for that
future lots of people find raising
babies rewarding i've heard
oh my god um i do not
uh but that sort of future payoff of
having you know that kind of close
family it's
i can't imagine being 65 and not having
that but then i'm not sure i'm
gonna like make the sacrifices today to
have that that's sort of
something i'm puzzling around in my head
apart from that just sort of
enjoying life and um helping out other
startups is a
is a nice way to feel like i'm giving a
little bit back without
taking my life at the moment so for me
that's enough
what do you think about i was looking to
ask i'm glad i remembered what do you
think about bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies generally
terrifying um
i don't understand it i invested a
little bit uh
it went up a lot i thought i was the
smartest person in the world it came
down again i sold before i lost any
money really
um it was too stressful
so there's a kind of two questions there
which like is crypto
what do you think of cryptocurrency long
term and is it useful versus like what
is your experience of riding the roller
coaster
over the last year long term i don't
know
i'm not i can see how it's interesting
but i think it's at the moment massively
over hyped and i
haven't really seen any cool
applications in reality yet that solve a
real human problem
that may change in future uh and then
the you know the
form a bit like the crazy speculation i
was you know checking the
price of ethereum every 15 minutes or
something it was that
that's just not healthy uh so i got out
and i'm again sleeping much better now
that i've
liquidated my crypto positions um
yeah what about you are you a believer i
i am so i did the whole 2017-2018 hype
cycle
got burnt pretty bad there and then i'm
a believer in blockchain as a technology
um i don't actually invest in bitcoin at
all um
i i invest in ethereum because i'm
slightly involved in building
a company in silicon valley in around
which is based on ethereum
but but i'm also not i'm fortunate that
i'm not checking the price every day
i'm a very significant ethereum holder
one of the top 5000 in the world
but i don't check the price because i
got burnt the first time
and i've just got this idea in my head
that um i'm holding for 10 years anyway
so irrespective of what happens i'd only
be checking the prices as if to inform a
decision
and i'm not going to make a decision if
it goes down 75
there's no decision if it goes up which
it did so yeah i think i have a healthy
relationship but i didn't the first time
yeah and also
the loss if i were to lose all the money
it wouldn't have a material impact on my
happiness or life i've heard smart
friends say
similar things which is basically take a
you're basically hedging into the risk
that this is like the future of the
economy and so take
between five and ten percent of your
like net net assets put it in crypto and
really leave it for 10 years yes and so
if it is like the future of money
you have a significant enough proportion
of that that you're like well set up
if it goes to zero you've still got the
other 1995 percent to sustain you
and i'm well diversified across various
different sort of asset classes so
if i genuinely lost all of my ethereum
holdings i don't think i'd lose a
night's sleep
do you know what i mean and that makes
it easy not to
but when i when i was at social chain
when i was i hadn't had an exit or i
hadn't taken anyone off the table at all
and the price went down it was like oh i
was going up and down with
you know with the price so again it
comes back to that video game mindset
and i think the detachment point
um you know when i started this podcast
tom i i did it for
very much you know when i read your
story
i thought [ __ ] this is exactly why i
started this podcast because it's
literally called the diary of a ceo
and what i was trying to achieve there
was to give up give people a more honest
view about what it takes to be a ceo
um and because i didn't necessarily i
think that it's been kind of you know
rock star like
jet ski you know whatever millionaires
loads of money private jet
um whereas there's a real as you've
explained cost
which people don't appreciate um of
being a ceo
and so when i when i read your story i
think in the papers and you were so
honest and open about the real nature of
being a ceo
the side of being a ceo that i can also
very much relate to
that's why i just needed you to come
here and to have this conversation with
me
what is the upside of being a ceo
i mean i think it is amazing i don't
want to sit here and kind of complain
about my life
um i think for
smart ambitious talented people
it can be incredibly remunerative i mean
i i'm
financially independent now as are you
right and it's
i think it um you can
create a lot of value but also like
capture some of that value personally
like and
make money like that's true you can be
um you can choose the people you work
with which i think is really really
really important so you can select the
people around you and to
um
choose who you spend your time with and
you get to create something if you're
successful
that random people in the street use and
that feeling of
um being a
having created something out of nothing
this thing would not exist if it weren't
for you and the team around you
and that i think that feeling is um is
amazing
and so i don't regret it at all um
i'm lucky now that i'm 35 and i don't
have to work really unless i want to
and all of my other friends are
successful in their own careers but
they're going to be working until
they're 60 or 65.
um and so yeah it's hard and it's
stressful but you know it's i wouldn't
change it for sure
i would do some things differently i'd
try to i'm not sure it would change the
outcome
but i think today for smart ambitious
people i think becoming a founder
is probably one of the best choices they
could make if they're
if they are of that mindset it's not for
everyone for sure but
i think if you're ambitious and
confident and
and want to create something it's it's
unparalleled
and the the sort of the foundation of
all of this the most important thing i
guess
is to make sure that you're happy yeah
and that i never thought about that i
mean that wasn't part of my upbringing
it was always secondary
yeah it was always like achieving or
accomplishing a goal of winning and the
thing that i think i personally i don't
know about anyone else any other
founders but i never
paid enough attention to whether i was
happy um
[Music]
uh which i think was a mistake
um and i'm now quite consciously doing
that
um yeah i think that's the probably the
downside
so many smart ambitious people are just
driven to kind of
jump over ever increasing hurdles um
without thinking about why
did you think happiness was the outcome
kind of yeah
i thought that was the end yeah sort of
like yeah
i didn't even really think about it
yeah it wasn't uh my family's always
been quite
um ambitious and driven and sort of
uh setting goals for you know
i was as kids um and i i know other
families where that is not the case
and i think talking more explicitly
about like
happiness and contentment and love and
relationships and
those things and then having a balance
i've never done balance
i think it's probably healthier if you
do have that you know the different
inputs and you can choose what's right
for you
so you i don't i don't want to draw the
point because i don't want to sound like
your therapist and we're almost done
here
but it really made me curious that what
you're saying about your family and
were your parents particularly goal
orientated yes
they were very hard on you or um
ambitious for us
certainly particularly my dad um
and i i'm a huge admirer of what he
started business
youngish i think he was he was 35 or 40
when he set up his business and he'd
retired by the time he's 45
um and so i always from a very young age
thought that sort of starting businesses
was
i never thought about starting business
actually i thought about running
businesses so i
had a privileged upbringing and my
parents were
around and sent me to good schools but
really pushed me you know it pushed me
to be
the top of the class and even when i was
top of the class they sort of pushed me
further and i'd sort of
say like come on well you know
i i did well in my exams to a point
where it's like
there is no more i can do in these
things like i've got all the top marks
um but they sort of didn't believe me
like no you must be
hiding something where's the so there
was always like um
i think my dad told me when i was 10 i
should go to oxford and study law
because it was the hardest course in the
world so
i went to oxford and studied law which
i'm not sure is super healthy actually
so yeah they're driven very very driven
and sort of
um because they you know
i think their parents as well pushed
them and um
my dad always likes to claim he came
from like this really working class up
bringing up in rockstar in manchester
it's just like
it's i had a mercedes like come on
and then you know with almost the same
breath he's like yeah we my mom had
horses
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
this sort of
working-class upcoming um yeah but they
they always worked hard they moved to
asia very young to make a better life
for themselves and they they did work
hard and they
provided us as kids with great
opportunities um
and i think now later in life all of us
have sort of realized that
um thinking a little bit more about
balance
and like happiness and relationships and
family
is more important as important certainly
and probably more important than um
sort of achievement and um and money
have you got to the crux of you what
makes you happy they're very not
foundational
for things um two or three things i know
definitely
learning um new skills whatever i really
really really love
that and um
sort of like my ex was really into
not really that's unfair she um
is it the languages of love like the way
you sort of experience love
yeah yeah and so for me acts of service
i hate the whole thing but i do but i
see
i see that in myself like i love to cook
for people i love to get friends
together
i love to you know cook a meal make
cocktails whatever it is sort of
like get a house in the countryside and
invite all my best friends
that i i really like being together with
groups of people that are
careful so learning new stuff being
together with friends and kind of
creating like cooking whatever whatever
it is so those
those things uh and i in time
raising kids maybe we will see um
that's more of an aspiration than a i
don't know
well listen tom thank you so much for um
coming and
doing this today i think what the thing
that um
you probably know but you might not
fully realize
um that i think is so incredibly
powerful is your willingness to be
vulnerable and honest
and i just wish there were more
entrepreneurs
at all stages in their journey that were
willing to
be that vulnerable because of how um how
much of a
how much of them reality is so much more
comforting than the like
this kind of um phony um
untouchable narrative you get from a lot
of entrepreneurs reality is such
much more of a comforting um place to be
because i can relate to that
and that gives peace to my own struggles
and hardships and those are an
unavoidable part of the human experience
and i think
entrepreneurs like yourself that have
been tremendously successful have
disrupted an industry and
achieved so much who are also willing to
be vulnerable
um are of a very special breed and we
need more of those people
so thank you so much and i appreciate
your time today thank you it's been a
lot of fun thank you
[Music]
you